Avec les enfants
je ne suis pas très bon comme euh
comme homme de l'armée parce que ce n'est pas comme euh ce que
je fais bien mais je sais que je suis
un très bon guerrier avec un couteau et
mon but et ma mission dans la vie est de
nourrir le  les gens et en fait à quoi
j'ai compris que je devais nourrir les
gens
[Musique]
il vient d'arriver chez le gars je lui ai demandé
tu peux me louer un joueur
un bistrot il me loue sans l'argent
le bistrot parce qu'il a compris que je
donnerai le  les gens je donnerai de la
nourriture aux réfugiés et je donnerai aussi de la
nourriture aux
personnes qui veulent avoir de la nourriture
et il a dit d'accord, prenez-le
gratuitement, j'ai pris les 25 personnes du
congé et beaucoup  de mon équipe
et je leur ai donné les lieux de travail maintenant, c'est
le problème avec le travail en Ukraine
parce que comme beaucoup d'entreprises sont
fermées
[Musique]
je pense que c'est de la première ligne culinaire 100 nous
cuisinons juste pas pour euh pour avoir de l'argent ou
pour donner aux gens un  bonheur nous
recherchons la
sécurité pour la sécurité de la vie
donc c'est comme ouais
[Musique]
a
toi